bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va
explorer les effets de la société sur
les individus à travers un exemple pop
pulp est pas loin
bienvenue dans la matrice
alors je tiens à préciser que je vais
faire ici une analyse complète de la
bonne et moi sauf si parce que ça me
prendrait au moins 42 épisodes et une
bonne douzaine de prozac
mais j'ai plutôt me concentrer sur
certains points qui me permettront de
montrer ce que je veux dire sur la
société
je sais qu'à moins d'avoir vécu dans une
grotte ces vingt dernières années il ya
peu de chances que vous soyez passés à
côté du phénomène matrix mais je vais
quand même en résumé les grandes lignes
au cas où vous auriez besoin d'un petit
récap réalisé par les frères et soeur ou
un chef qui en 1999 je marque ici une
petite parenthèse
lorsque j'ai écrit cette chronique en
diois chose qui n'avait pas encore
achevé sa procédure de changement de
sexe et n'était donc pas encore connue
sous le nom de lily whites qui c'est
pourquoi je parle des frères et soeurs
watch ski et non des soeurs goitschel
ski matrix est un film d'anticipation
slaj science-fiction sache que me fous
action hashtag super film qui a
révolutionné les codes du blockbuster
hollywoodien intelligent fun et surtout
très classe on a vu naître un film qui
arrivait enfin à dépasser les summum du
divertissement sans pour autant demander
aux spectateurs de débrancher son
cerveau en entrant dans la salle de
cinéma
thomas sanderson donc joué par keanu
reeves est un travailleur lambda à la
vie chiante qui la nuit devient un
pirate geek sous le pseudonyme de neo en
se faisant recruter par trinity j'me par
carrie anne moss et morpheus interprété
par laurence fishburne
il prendra conscience que l'humanité
vient en réalité dans un avenir post
apocalyptique et que le monde qu'il
connaît n'est qu'une interface créé par
des machines pour à saverne humanité
qu'elle cultive et de laquelle elle tire
son énergie
seules les personnes libérer de
l'emprise de la matrice ont conscience
de la réalité et se bat pour sauver
l'humanité de l'asservissement des
machines en temps normal l'équipe de
morpheus ne libère que des personnes
assez jeune
car leur esprit n'a pas encore eu le
temps d'être complètement conditionnée
par la matrice
il accepte ainsi mieux
monde réel quand on leur révèle la
supercherie en revanche passé un certain
âge
l'esprit est tellement habitué au monde
qu'il a toujours connu qu'il ne peut pas
croire à la nouvelle réalité qu'on lui
propose
et il résiste ainsi de toutes ses forces
contre son acceptation la raison pour
laquelle morpheus a tout de même libéré
néo c'est parce que ce dernier est l'élu
celui qui devrait être capable de sauver
l'humanité notamment en surpassant les
fameux agent de la matrice d espèce de
super flics ont costume cravate et aux
capacités surhumaines qui peuvent
prendre possession de n'importe quel
humain encore connectés à la matrix donc
voilà pour l'histoire
pour ce qui est du sens ou des messages
plus ou moins cachés il faut d'abord
savoir qu'ils sont très très nombreux
ah ben c'est bien ça il ya plus de
niveaux de lecture dans matrix que
d'explosions dans la filmographie
complète de michael bay du coup de façon
assez évidente je vais pas revenir sur
tous les niveaux de sens qu'on peut
trouver dans matrix
par conséquent l'un des premiers sens de
matrix c'est avant tout se placer comme
une critique de la surconsommation et de
la société capitaliste et aliénante de
façon générale comme l'expliqué l'agent
smith à morpheus la première réaction de
la matrice était parfaite une espèce de
paradis terrestre où tous les humains il
est heureux mais ce havre de paix a été
un désastre politique
il semble donc d'après les machines que
la seule façon d'élever des humains soit
de créer une société capitaliste et
aliénante au sein de laquelle se joue
des rapports de pouvoir et de domination
et de fait c'est bien ce que représente
la matrice les passages qui se déroule
dans la matrice font presque toujours
référence à la société de consommation
au travail abrutissant et aliénant et à
la domination
les gens sont habillés pratiquement de
la même façon avec des dunks noir et ce
conformisme vestimentaire n'est jamais
rendue de façon aussi évidente que par
les agents véritable gardien des normes
de la matrice on peut également
remarquer que la première fois que
morpheus décrit la matrice aného il
n'emploie que des images de la société
aliénée en citant divers éléments de
contrôle
la matrice est universel
elle est omniprésente elle est avec nous
ici en ce moment même tu la vois chaque
fois que tu regarde par la fenêtre ou
lorsque tu allumes la télévision tursan
sa présence quand tu pars au travail
quand tu vas à l'église au camp de péter
facture elle est le monde qu on
superpose à ton regard pour t'empêcher
de voir la vérité quelle vérité
le fait que tu aies un esclave neo
on voit que si on remplace matrice par
société capitaliste dans cet extrait ça
marche quand même plutôt bien mais un
exemple qui à mon sens permet de montrer
immédiatement le caractère aliénant de
la vie que mènent neo c'est le fait
qu'il travaille dans un open space et
l'open space c'est le mal
c'est le symbole incontestable est
parfaitement accepté du contrôle social
capitaliste celui qui va anéantir notre
individualité et nous transformer en
moutons accumulateurs et névrosé a ciblé
de la même velléités quand rhododendrons
sociale démocrate ou mescaline
bon je m'emporte mais je vais vous
expliquer l'open space c'est tout
simplement la déclinaison au monde du
travail moderne d'un modèle de prison
inventé par l'économiste anglais jeremy
bentham jeremy bentham gène amis donc
est un philosophe anglais né à londres
en 1948 et qui est notamment connu pour
être le co fondateur avec son ami john
stuart mill de l'école de pensée dite
des utilitariste alors je vais pas
m'étendre sur les utilitaires ici
aujourd'hui parce qu'on va clairement
pas avoir le temps mais j'en parlerai de
ça l'idée de bentham à la base c'était
juste d'économiser du pognon créer une
prison qui ait besoin d'employer le
moins de personnes possible pour
surveiller les prisonniers alors au
début des années 1800 il arrive avec un
concept assez énorme en fait un plan de
crise on qui serait construit de façon
circulaire avec en son centre une tour
avec un unique gardien et toutes les
cellules ouvertes ouverte dans le sens à
la vue du gardien à quoi est ce qu'ils
disent est finalement un mec tout seul
peut surveiller la prison il suffit de
mettre un mec dans la tour du milieu qui
seraient cachés à une façon que les
prisonniers puissent pas le voir et puis
rien que le fait qu'il puisse
possiblement être en train de regarder
n'importe laquelle des cellules pas tous
les prisonniers vont se comporter comme
s'ils étaient en train de se faire
regarder
soit l'appel du contrôle social par la
surveillance finalement il arrivera j'en
ai refait reconstruit réellement une de
ces prisons de son vivant mais après lui
des philosophes reprenant certaines de
ses idées et le mettront au plan des
réelles construction qui existe encore
aujourd'hui
l'open space c'est pareil on crée des
espaces de travail ouverts de façon peu
tout le monde de voir ce que tu fais et
là c'est encore plus fort c'est qu'elle
même plus besoin de gardiens puisque
c'était collègues qui vont observer et
qui vont stigmatiser si jamais tu fais
des trucs tu as bien des derniers
arrivés étaient première partie qui
passe sa journée à facebook au boulot
tout le monde le voit hélas le contrôle
social s'organise de l'intérieur parce
qu'en fait quand on y réfléchit ça peut
être facile au moins moralement de
s'attaquer à l'autorité parce que on a
le sentiment de se poser à quelque chose
de plus grand que nous donc quelque part
c'est valorisant le côté seul contre
l'autorité ou à la limite avec tous ces
égos la mars contre l'autorité mais là
c'est pas pareil parce que c'est pas à
l'autorité pour s'attaque
c'est à nos égos et c'est beaucoup plus
difficile de s'attaquer à nos égos le
parallèle entre l'open space et le
panopticon de bentham ça vient en fait
du philosophe michel foucault dans un
livre de 1975 intitulé surveiller et
punir
ouais parce qu'en fait je l'aimais pas
précisé mais la prison de bentham elle
s'appelle le palpitant où panoptique
punk qui connaissent juste le mot en
grec mikis plus classe mais pareil ce
que nous dit michel foucault dans
surveiller et punir c'est en fait très
intéressant parce que ça nous permet de
comprendre comment a évolué la société à
travers son désir de contrôle des
individus ce qui nous expliquent ces
campagnes sous l'ancien régime
on n'avait rien à faire de contrôle est
vraiment comment les gens manger épicé
kage de ce qu'on faisait c'était définir
quand il dit quelque chose de mal que tu
veuilles tu tues tu sais 2000 déchets
avec un moine unijambiste est une vache
normande en nombre de certifications
scato masochiste à la pleine lune
tu te c'est punir mais bon après on s'en
foutait de contrôler les individus au
jour le jour dans la société
tout au long de leur vie mais bon ça
c'était avant
après la chute de l'ancien régime il
écrit que la société cherche maintenant
plutôt à contrôler l'individu à
neutraliser son état dangereux à
modifier ces dispositions criminelle et
à ne sais c'est qu'une fois ce
changement obtenu on voit bien à
l'avènement d'une société omniprésente
qui veut endiguer les passions et
contrôler l'individu à n'importe quel
moment sa vie et se contrôle à
d'ailleurs été tellement intériorisé
les individus eux mêmes qui se font
maintenant les agents de sa continuité
et c'est bien ça qui est montré dans
matrix mais de façon beaucoup plus imagé
parce que si dans la société de tous les
jours nous sommes contrôlés et nous
faisons partie du contrôle en permanence
dans la matrice
ce contrôle est symbolisée par les
agents et il est particulièrement
intéressant de remarquer que toute
personne qui n'aurait pas été
préalablement déconnecté de la matrice
peut potentiellement se transformer en
agent ça montre bien que toutes
personnes intégrées au système est en
fait un agent de contrôle de ce système
mais trêve de salamalecs j'ai un
cassoulet sur le feu alors rentrons dans
le vif du sujet ça n'attend jamais le
cassoulet une des idées que je trouve
absolument brillance dans les films
matrix ça a été de montrer de façon
physique des éléments qu'il est
normalement invisibles dans la société
tous les jours je parle ici des règles
sociales des codes sociaux
bref des normes pour vivre en société on
entend souvent qu'il faut respecter des
normes
certaines sont faciles évidente on les
apprend en plus jeune âge ça va être
dire bonjour à la dame ou ne pas mettre
de l'eau dans son nez d'autres sont plus
subtiles et nécessite un long de
l'apprentissage comme reconnaître
approximativement le statut social de la
personne qui est en face de nous et
adaptez votre langage en conséquence
toutes ces règles tacites est
communément admise rentre donc tout ce
que nous pouvons appeler des codes
sociaux
si les codes sociaux sont invisibles
dans la société
ils sont pourtant bien visible dans
matrix le code le machin vers où a
défilé tout au long du film
c'est sale et greg de la matrice c'est
son code et le pouvoir de les lui c'est
justement celui de ne pas suivre le code
voir et connaître les règles de la
matrice mais être capable de s'en
abstraire
et c'est sur ce point particulier mais
je veux faire de parallèle entre
l'activité sociologique et les
personnages de matrix les personnages
dans matrix ceux qui sont encore branché
à la matrice ne voit pas la société une
voix pas le code
ils ne peuvent pas s'en abstraire ce qui
n'est pas le cas des gens qui vivent
dans le monde réel des personnages qui
ont été libérés et qui voit ainsi le
code défiler sur les écrans et peuvent
donc objective et c'est à dire voir de
façon objective
ce code de la matrice qui peut être
décodé par les opérateurs tels que tank
qui vient directement du monde réel et
qui regarde donc la matrice comme d'un
point de vue extérieur
c'est exactement ce day2 fin de
sociologues observer la société ait
tenté de faire un compte rendu des
règles qui la régissent
et voilà landais coeur du problème
de la même façon qu'il peut être très
difficile d'accepter la réalité qu'on en
sort de la matrice il est très difficile
pour les gens habitant dans une société
d'accepter les propos du sociologue
quand ils vont à l'encontre des
perceptions qui l'ont du monde social
c'est notamment l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles le discours des sociologues a
autant de mal à percer dans le discours
ambiant général un peu le comprendre
parce que portant scientifiques
traditionnelles va la faire un discours
sur la masse du noyau où la distance des
étoiles ce n'est pas a priori quelque
chose de perceptible donc on va croire
sur parole mais si quelqu'un va lui
parler du monde social de sa classe
sociale de comment les gens évoluent en
société là c'est quelque chose dont les
gens peuvent se sentir investi
puisqu'ils vivent dans cette société est
donc tout le monde se pensent légitime
pour produire un discours cohérent là
dessus sauf que sans avoir une méthode
spécifique
le discours n'est absolument pas
cohérent ni scientifique ne sera que le
résultat de la socialisation sous la
forme de ce que durkheim appelé
l'illusion de la transparence
en effet chaque sujet social en tant
qu'homme
parce qu'il est ipso facto sa vente de
l'ordre
c'est notamment un problème sur lequel
est revenue le sociologue françois dubet
dans un article de 2002 intitulé
pourquoi ne croîtront pas les
sociologues du bes à un spécialiste de
la sociologie de l'application il a
notamment beaucoup travaillé sur les
institutions scolaires et ce qu'il
remarque c'est que le discours
scientifique
il produit sur ces mêmes institutions ne
sont en général pas prise au sérieux par
les acteurs même de ces institutions à
savoir le monde des professeurs on
pourrait pourtant s'attendre à ce que
les professeurs qui devrait normalement
être habitué à lire des articles
scientifiques reconnaissent ici
l'autorité du sociologue
force est de constater que ce n'est pas
le cas mais on ne peut pas leur en
vouloir parce que de leur point de vue
les propos du sociologue sont
effectivement fou dans son article dubé
prend l'exemple de la baisse du niveau
scolaire dont on entend parler depuis un
bon bout d'années maintenant
bon et bien à ce sujet la très très
grande majorité des professeurs est
d'accord pour dire que il y a une réelle
baisse du niveau scolaire
pourtant du point de vue du sociologue
cette affirmation est fausse et avec des
preuves à l'appui et pour ça il suffit
de comparer les résultats scolaires de
ces cinquante dernières années
on va raisonner en termes de classes
d'âge une classe d'âge c'est tous les
individus rentrant dans une classe aux
ménages par exemple tous les individus
rentre en cp en 2015 forment une classe
d'âge qui passeront leur bac en 2005
bon et bien en 1950 50 % d'une classe
d'âge obtenait le certificat d'études
primaires le certificat d'études
primaires c'est le diplôme qu'on passe à
la fin du cm2 pour entrer au collège
donc uniquement la moitié de la
population
obtenez le certificat permettant de leur
entrée au collège
en 2060 5 % d'une classe d'âge obtient
le baccalauréat en regardant les
chiffres c'est indéniable le niveau
scolaire a réellement augmenter puisque
dans les années cinq ans c'est la moitié
de la population qui n'allait pas
jusqu'au collège
alors que dans les années 2000 65 %
d'une classe d'âge obtient le
baccalauréat est encore sur les prix les
chiffres sur l'entrée au collège je
pense qu'on était vraiment pas loin des
100 % mais si les chiffres sont c'est
incontestable pourquoi sociologue et
professeur ne tombe-t-il pas d'accord
parce que le sociologue regarde la
société du dessus comme quelque chose de
global alors que 200 points de vue
le professeur a effectivement pu
constater une baisse de niveau et oui
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre ça dans
les années 50 les professeurs recevait
50 % d'une classe d'âge au collège et
c'était évidemment les 50 % les mieux
éduquées de la population qui avait
effectivement un bon niveau avec la
démocratisation scolaire de plus en plus
d'individus
été capable de fréquenter les
établissements scolaires pendant les
durs est de plus en plus longues
de cette façon on a vu arriver dans des
classes de plus en plus haute des élèves
d'origine de plus en plus modestes qui
avant d'accéder pas du tout à ces
classes là donc du point de vue du
professeur qui avaient devant eux
uniquement une élite intellectuelle se
sont retrouvés avec des classes beaucoup
plus mixte socialement et donc de leur
point de vue le niveau a effectivement
baissé puisque les bons élèves se sont
faits de plus en plus rare et c'est bien
là le travail du sociologue comprendre
la société de façon globale sans être
éblouis par ses expériences personnelles
un peu de la même façon qu'il faut
accepter que la matrice est un monde
factice avant de pouvoir accéder au
monde réel mais l'une des principales
raisons pour lesquelles il est parfois
très difficiles d'accès tels discours
sociologique c'est parce que il est très
difficile de se défaire de sa
socialisation la socialisation c'est le
phénomène créé par les instances qui
nous ont permis de devenir des êtres
sociaux
on distingue souvent deux types de
socialisation la socialisation primaire
qui intervient pendant la toute petite
enfance et la socialisation secondaire
qui intervient tout au long de notre vie
pour simplifier vraiment très rapidement
la socialisation primaire les plus ou
moins fait par nos parents notre famille
et la socialisation secondaires plutôt
faite par nos pairs c'est à dire nos ego
du même âge et le monde du travail et le
monde extérieur de façon générale
oui c'est évident qu'on subit une
socialisation tout au cours de la vie
quand on arrive dans une nouvelle
entreprise par exemple
bon bah il faut qu'on se fasse à
l'entreprise qu'on accepte les petites
règles qui régissent l'entreprise
parce que ici on appelle bug bobby et
puis la machine à café sait jamais avant
10h bon bah il faut apprendre tout ça et
c'est une forme de socialisation
mais s'il ya des formes de socialisation
comme ça qui relève plus de l'adaptation
d'autres sont profondément ancrées et
quand corpore dans nos êtres et plus
spécifiquement dans nos corps le
sociologue pierre bourdieu avait pris
l'habitude d'utiliser le mode habitus
pour parler de ce type de socialisation
alors pour simplifier l'habitus ça va
être la socialisation de laquelle on ne
peut pas s'abstraire c'est souvent la
socialisation qatar vient dans la petite
enfance l'association primaires c'est
socialisation primaires sont souvent les
socialistes
on les plus fortes en termes de
construction d'identités puisque c'est
là qu'on va apprendre à gérer nos
identités en termes de genre de classe
sociale même de spatialité puisqu'on ne
se comportent pas pareil dans le monde
social si on est masculin ou féminin
si on est fils de cadre ou fils
d'ouvrier ou si on habite au plein coeur
de paris aux oubliés de la campagne et
si on peut connaître de nombreux
changements au cours de notre vie comme
changer de sexe
simplement déménagé ou connaître une
mobilité sociale ascendante
il faudra toute notre vie qu'on lutte
contre cette socialisation primaire qui
nous a défini en tant qu'individu
sociétale pour prendre l'exemple de
bourdieu
il a mis au point le concept d' invictus
en parallèle avec celui de violence
symbolique en analysant sa propre
situation
lui-même vient d'un petit village paumé
de la campagne étant très bon élève il a
réussi à rentrer à l'école normale
supérieure est donc monté à paris pour
faire des études de philosophie une fois
agrégé de philosophie il avait alors
accompli le nec plus ultra de la
formation scolaire
il ya des acquis la plus haute
distinction en termes institutionnels
qu'on pouvait alors acquérir à l'époque
oui parce qu'on parle d'une époque où
c'était encore la classe de faire des
lettres et de la philosophie et on
pourrait croire qu'après avoir réussi
tout ça il aurait pu se dire bon mais
c'est bon cette fois j'ai réussi tu très
légitime et bah c'est pas si simple
et oui parce que en montant à paris en
devenant élève de l'école normale
supérieure il a alors côtoyer des
étudiants parisiens qui avaient toujours
grandi et évolué dans ce milieu très
éduquée et connaissait déjà tous les
codes sociaux pour se faire accepter par
l'intelligentsia de l'époque
or lui ces codes sociaux on ne lui avait
jamais enseigné il a dû tout apprendre
tout seul et même s'il ne semble
finalement pas trop mal sorti
il a toujours ressenti l'impression de
ne pas être à sa place dans ce monde
intellectuel que ce soit vrai ou pas il
a toujours eu l'impression que ces
enfants de bonne famille qui connaissait
tous les codes sociaux de bienséance se
moquer de lui pour ne pas connaître ces
mêmes codes et c'est comme ça qu'il a
inventé le concept de violence
symbolique
une violence qui n'est ni physique ni
verbale mais qui se ressent au plus
profond de son maître comme le fait de
ne pas être à sa place d'être exclue
d'un milieu social donné et c'est la
dure loi de la vie
us c'est que même après avoir analysé
tout ce que je viens de vous dire et
avoir très bien compris que cette
violence symbolique ils la ressentent et
uniquement parce qu'il venait de la
campagne et qui n'étaient pas habituées
aux codes parisiens
ça n'a jamais empêché de ressentir cette
violence avoir conscience du caractère
construit des éléments du monde social
ne rend pas pour autant ces éléments
moins vrai je croyais que c'etait pas
réel l'esprit pense que ça l'est si on
se fait tuer dans la matrice
on a ri si on ne peut survivre sans
l'esprit si j'ai autant insister là
dessus c'est parce que c'est quelque
chose que l'on voit bien dans matrix et
qui est montré je trouve d'une façon
brillance et subtile presque 10 mois
chaque style sont subtiles comme afrique
ces sorties on a souvent reproché aux
comédiens incarnant neo et aux acteurs
jouant trinity est morte et avoir un jeu
très lisse monolithique laissant passer
très très peu d'émotions
de fait ils ont un visage souvent
impassible face à la plupart des
situations
c'est également le cas de la plupart des
personnages qui exprime la sensation de
façon pour le moins très subtil si ce
n'est quasiment inexistante
loin d'être à mettre sur le compte d'un
mauvais oeil acteurs c'est au contraire
un choix réel de réalisation de la part
des frères et soeur ou un chef qui cela
montre que les faits qu'à la matrice sur
les humains et de les mener à une
déshumanisation totale
l'exemple le plus parlant étant
évidemment celui des agents qui
incarnent les règles de la matrice
appliquée de façon la plus extrême
il ne laisse transparaître aucune
émotion il parle de façon lente haché et
détaché en toutes circonstances et il
porte des vêtements qui ont font les
incarnations sans identité de la
réussite capitaliste par la suite il est
intéressant de remarquer que même une
fois libéré de l'emprise de la matrice
les individus restent assez froid et
déshumanisée comme si malgré leur
connaissance de la réalité et des règles
de la matrice il restait le résultat de
cette déshumanisation
comme pour appuyer ce propos il est par
ailleurs notable que les seuls
personnages un tant soit peu expressif
sont les jeunes qui ont été libérés
suffisamment tout pour échapper à la
déshumanisation où se
comme tank et loser qui sont nés sur la
cité libre de sion et qui n'ont donc
jamais connu le conditionnement de la
matrice le message est donc clair il est
très difficile de se défaire des effets
de la socialisation
même en prenant conscience de la réalité
des choses et du monde qui nous entoure
nous restons le produit de la société
qui nous a créés et voilà cet épisode de
sociologie qui est maintenant terminée
je vous remercie de l'avoir suivi
jusqu'au bout dans vraiment merci
alors j'ai pas encore de facebook
twitter et quoi que ce soit vous pouvez
cependant laïque et la vidéo l'a
partagée si elle vous a plu et sinon ben
moi je vous dis à bientôt et en
attendant je vous conseille de vous
abonner à la chaîne sociologique
sinon nous sommes capables de vous faire
résonner directement dans les oreilles
le dernier album de justin bieber
partout où vous irez prenais la bonne
décision mais ciom personnes
complètement con on est bien d'accord